the war has begun and one question
remains
man
on July 6 two years under house arrest
you haven't had any contact with Hank
for home time you hmm
real heroes
and man in the wash Tina now not actual
size awesome
if only cap could see you now
[Music]
where were ant-man and the wasps did you
see the monsoon where was Tim Jack good
question
no I mean really I have no idea I mean I
don't remember being asked to be in
their movie just saying maybe they were
on their way but they went subatomic
maybe they were they're pretty tiny and
there were definitely some ants of a
condor so maybe they're in the same
places hawker Kimura saw spider-man I
was really looking forward to meeting
the wasps
yeah no not that clear hey everybody
it's Charlie we got new ant-man in the
wasps to break down new Captain Marvel
and some cool Nick Fury Black Panther
stuff because samuel l.jackson has been
doing a bunch of interviews for
incredible so of course everyone's
asking him about Avengers for stuff so
if you're finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get all the
Marvel videos there's a new round of the
Infinity war blu-ray giveaway all you
have to tend to that is be a subscriber
or leave a comment on the video I'll
name a new winner at the end of this but
obviously they're still playing on that
infinity war funny moment where was
ant-man what's going on they've been
doing this ever since infinity war came
out they started to promote ant-man the
wasp right is that what's dropping in
theaters like everything has been
building towards this where the hell is
ant-man
there's a couple funny new scenes like I
love the way that she makes fun of him
like all cap would be so proud of you
now like Evangeline Lilly looks like she
is on fire for this entire movie
hopefully if it does turn out that she's
one of the people that turns into ashes
during this timeline she gets some
really badass moments during Avengers 4
when they fix everything finally there's
a couple more funny moments with the
little Matchbox cars this car even looks
like it's painted to be a Hot Wheels
like you would mistake it for a toy if
you found it on the ground we finally
get some dialogue from Randall Parts
character he's just a government
official that's overseeing ant-man's
house arrest remember he turned himself
in after they all escaped from the raft
while he was on the lamp they're kind of
ambiguous about the amount of time the
past between the end of Civil War when
they all broke out in the beginning of
infinity war because of how much cap in
Black Widow have changed like they've
been on the land doing Secret Avengers
stuff this whole time it's implied it's
been a little while but usually the
actors don't get details like that like
the writers the directors will say it's
been a good long
while no surprise Kevin Feige wants to
slowly move away from using hard dates
inside movies just because of that whole
spider-man homecoming timeline problem
but also with all this ant-man the wasp
stuff they just dropped a bunch of
interviews and behind the scenes
Michael Douglas is fantastic remember
way back to comic-con when they were
promoting age of Ultron in the first
ant-man movie and he had that comment
about popping a lot of cherries greatest
gross old man comment ever I never
thought I would say this to you but
we're also popping your cherry as well
it's very awkward but uh I've hopped
enough cherries don't think I don't want
to just talk about that for the next
hour now he's also talking probably a
little more than he should about the
plot of ant-man the wasp in Janet Van
Dyne he does confirm that there is a
flashback to them 30 years ago so now we
know we're gonna see them doing really
cool stuff I don't know how many scenes
that are going to be he just said that
there would be moments with them 30
years younger and he said that the way
that they learn about Janet Van Dyne is
is that there's a signal that comes out
of the quantum realm it has something to
do with Scott Lang but that might have
something to do with this moment here
where he's wearing the old version of
the costume and he went into the quantum
realm during the first movie so I'm just
expecting them to have a couple scenes
that will link that event him going into
the quantum realm and then coming back
out then going onto Captain America
Civil War and then them learning about
Janet Van Dyne and sort of trying to
find her through the course of this
movie if it wasn't clear too they also
implied that the reason why Hank Pym in
hope are on the run is because they
refused to sign the sokovia accords so
this is cat-and-mouse chase throughout
the film you have the ghost but you also
have the government that wants to catch
them too everybody wants to get them
that sweet Pym particle honey
but he also teases his relationship with
Goliath who's played by Laurence
Fishburne's character big comic book
character in the history of Marvel
Comics but now he's supposed to be a
professor at Berkeley and it's sort of
like a Steve Jobs Bill Gates situation
it doesn't necessarily confirm he's
going to be one of the villains of the
film but they do have that rivalry going
on getting into Avengers 4 territory so
Samuel
l.jackson did an interview recently
where he confirmed that Marvel said that
he would be meeting up with Black
Panther in a future film because the
interview happened recently I assume
he's talking about Avengers 4 because
they'll all eventually come back from
the ashes and then the actor himself
speculating about his character just
said I feel like Nick Fury would know
exactly what's going on in Wakanda
because of who Nick Fury is in the way
he collects information he would just
say oh yeah that's the black panther
over there doing his black panther thing
so you just have to imagine Sam Jackson
spinning all these ideas he does say
that he pitches a lot of ideas to Marvel
like he was really upset that he wasn't
in the black panther film that's when
Marvel was like no you're not gonna be
in this one but you will meet up with
Black Panther in the future so moving
into Captain Marvel territory brie
Larson also just did an interview
talking about her character a little bit
so I'll just play that here no I'm just
making the movie right now and that part
feels kind of the same I mean the only
difference is that there's more people
there there's it is but it's that stuff
is my favorite part because that's where
you find the character you know for me
it's all about like how far can I take
myself to kind of reprogram my brain and
rewrote reprogram my body to learn
something new about myself and so this
has been an amazing challenge he's so so
strong she can move planets so to me it
was like how far can I go with this
strength
I think that they should just get
excited I'm really proud of what it is
that we're making and I think that all
of the hype and all the anticipation
they're actually still filming so like
every once in a while the actors will
leave set to go do award shows and brie
Larson was doing some stuff in real life
just separately over the weekend so
what's happening right now heading into
comic-con is that they'll finish filming
Captain Marvel before that happens not
expecting any kind of big trailer or
anything like that but maybe they'll
drop some footage most of the Marvel
stuff you see a Comic Con will be from
Sony because of venom and all the
spider-man stuff that's going on so they
have the animated movie but they also
have spider-man 2 I don't think they're
gonna tease too much of that because
they'll be filming it they'll actually
be filming spider-man homecoming to wall
Comic Con is happening so normally I
would say that Tom Holland would come to
Comic Con and just like wave at
everybody and then go back to filming
but because Marvel Studios isn't doing
anything I think they're gonna lay off
of Tom Holland so don't expect any of
the big Marvel actors to show up unless
they're gonna be there for another movie
like Henry Cavill is gonna be promoting
Mission Impossible 6 so he might be
there promoting more DC stuff while he's
there like hey there's a Man of Steel
sequel coming so don't worry Comic Con
is gonna be crazy there'll be a billion
different videos and things happening
I'll do more videos as we get closer
explaining what the schedules gonna be
in the videos that I'm planning on doing
it'll all be great no worries
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Luis Cortez please private
message me so I can get your contact
details click here for more New Avengers
4 and click here for more new phase 4
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]